chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel tonight on the tactics and the
strategy there could not be a better
time to take action to help more people
join our workforce part of the house
speakers pitch for support of a
five-year farm bill extension but as GOP
leaders try to round up the final votes
to pass it
the house freedom caucus is trying to
flex some muscle on immigration in
exchange for support on the farm bill
the vast majority of our members believe
that we should have a vote on
immigration before we have a vote on the
farm bills we were not able to convince
any of our members from God to go from
no to yes on the farm bill and so we
will have further discussions tonight
with leadership but at this point there
is no deal to be made
this comes as some moderate House
Republicans are trying to force Ryan's
hand on an immigration bill by being
willing to work with Democrats at least
20 Republicans have signed on to the
so-called discharge petition Ryan has
tried to hold them off by saying he
wants an immigration plan that President
Trump would be willing to sign we wanted
to see if we can do our our own
immigration bills we've been laboring to
get to 18 it's clear that we don't have
218 for a specific bill House Democratic
Leader Nancy Pelosi called the effort by
GOP moderates to force immigration
action very beautiful rank-and-file and
really even more established than that
members in that house and in the house
on Democratic and Republican side have
come together on a bipartisan bill that
they have constructed that they have
gained support for and that they have
made it now part of the discharge
petition conservatives are not amused by
moderates making this play and are
signaling what they want the idea being
something close to a security first plan
offered by Judiciary Chairman Bob
Goodlatte the fix is we got to keep
compromising within the conference as
Republicans on the Goodlatte bill and
find the sweet spot that will pass into
law Fox has learned GOP leaders plan to
offer the freedom caucus a date next
month to consider that conservative
immigration bill if the freedom caucus
doesn't take it leadership could pull
the farm bill from the floor tomorrow
and hold it until the house has taken
action on that immigration package